very great pleasure to welcome in today
for Alexei microfinance
after the - thank you thank you so this
is you see there's some mismatch between
this title and that one and but the
basic idea what I want to do over the
next hour is so take you on the journey
that microfinance has been true over the
last 10 or so years and it's an
interesting journey because it sort of
has a little bit of many things I think
a little bit of economics a little bit
of interesting politics and a little bit
of interesting sociology and sociology
of knowledge I think all built into it
so in some ways it's a it's a
example of where you know once you start
unpacking what happened over the last 10
years just you didn't get you get to see
a little bit of how academics work how
the world works how those things
interact and sometimes bizarre ways so
it's it's a so it's a sort of story that
as you probably I suspect to this
audience you probably know what
microfinance is microfinance is very
very small loans for mostly for very
poor people all over the world it's
about I would say about ten years ago
resonance was really at the maximum of
its hype and so it was it was the next
you know thing that's going to lift
everyone out of poverty and Muhammad
Yunus I think deservedly or won the
Nobel Peace Prize for for his promotion
of microcredit maybe like the mid 2000
so that was kind of the high point of
microcredit and there was a lot of
discussion of how microcredit will sort
of replace the standard to fight poverty
that you see you know not working so
well across the world so there was this
very much the sense that now we've
finally found the answer and then
something happened kind of at the end of
the 2000s which is also interesting
which is sort of represented by this
these courts the wall street journal'
Court is morally more descriptive and
but there was a much more prescriptive
articles as well in the New York Times
for example saying that basically
microcredit was yet another promise that
Fair Oaks so there was there was a clear
sense in which not only was there a
political crisis in in microcredit
political crisis was read as
representative of some deeper crisis in
in this whole line of thinking and so
there was a sense in which you know
people people were talk i think they was
certainly talk about how you know
microcredit was import impoverishing
people and how this was the whole thing
was I think I was at a talk
day before yesterday where a lady held
forth on how this was the the the latest
end of the capitalist conspiracy so you
know you can get the whole gamut of
views and suddenly she cited some of the
same evidence that that that I'm going
to talk about in a minute let me store
so what happened actually so what
happened specifically a two three three
I think quite sort of us you know very
distinct and very salient in incidents
one was in in in India the the state
government of a state in South South
India or Andhra Pradesh which had the
biggest penetration of microcredit
declared that microcredit
was responsible for large numbers of
suicides among poor people and therefore
would need serious regulation and
possibly a ban and they discussed a
whole range of options the first step in
that process the the government the the
government of Andhra Pradesh basically I
would say announced that people
announced a little bit strong that
people don't need to repay their micro
loans that this this was not they should
not feel obligated to pay which in the
end is a fairly effective way to
demolish a lending institution because
you know if people don't pay their loans
there's not much else that's left of
this so that was the what happened in in
India so there was a as a result
basically loan pain
and stopped completely and three out of
the four major microcredit organizations
in the state of Andhra Pradesh basically
immediately headed into bankruptcy and
two of them were bailed out one of them
went bankrupt the oldest microcredit
organization went bankrupt so there was
there was a very clear policy push which
is which what happened Bangladesh is
slightly different in Bangladesh the
there was mama Yunus was from Bangladesh
had once dare to run for president in
motivation so he was persona non grata
with various political political figures
in Bangladesh and at some point the
there was some set of accusations of
corruption which were later I think
proved to be false or at least never
proved which were leveled against him
and then through that channel he was
eased out from being the head of head of
Grameen Bank and a whole other set of
people were put in place as either
regulators or participants in the system
so there was a again a substantial push
back against microcredit and from a
slightly different angle the last of
these the events which which is sort of
across the world in Mexico Compartamos
which is one of the largest microcredit
ogron's in Mexico had an IPO where they
raised over a hundred million dollars
and this generated a kind of kind of I
would say shock response in a lot of the
kind of a lot of the press both in
Mexico and in the US we and the reaction
was how are these guys making so much
money so there was an end that that came
with a whole moral compass which which
led to discussions of whether or not
this is a new form of user user II
Mahmoud Yunus interestingly came out
against Compartamos arguing that this
was reinvention or usury and that there
is a sense in which microcredit has gone
wrong so there was this this is sort of
just different facets of a crisis which
all happened basically in this period
between you know beginning of 2009 and
the middle of 2010 all of these things
basically happen at the same time and
all over suddenly you get this newspaper
reports which say that you know
microcredit this kind of kind of it was
sort of you know another of these
stories of you know something that
sounded too good to be true and was
indeed too good to be true
now so I wonder what I want to do is
able to analyze this crisis I want to
see why why this crisis happened why it
could happen in this space and how in a
sense we academics and I think a lot of
a lot of other people donors and others
have colluded with making the making
with making this sort of crisis happen
in a sense that we we were part of
intellectual process that contributed to
this crisis so let me start by I think
what happened I would summarize that in
in sort 3 3 ingredients and I want to
spend most of the time detailing them so
one I think is on our side I think there
was a willingness to believe credulity
I think we were willing willing to
believe that there is going to be but
the financial market could come to the
rescue and that message I think
resonated with a lot of people a lot of
people liked the idea that somehow after
all these you know failed intervention
there's going to be you know the
financial markets will write in and save
the world
so that idea appealed to lots of people
that rhetoric appeal to a lot of people
and I think a lot of academics a lot of
donors and a lot of people in the
protector really like that so that was
that was clearly clearly part of the
story you know point out where I think
we there was clearly acts of credulity
things we should not have believed we
believed second I think there was given
these incentives that you know everybody
believed that microcredit is somehow
going to going to save the world the
incentive that that created were very
clear for the microcredit organizations
once once they are certified as being
saving you know this new new way to save
the poor there were parts of money
available if they could only expand as
fast as day so basically how do you make
a make money for microcredit
organization you have to give more loans
so if you could lend faster the capital
was flowing in people were just standing
outside the door with checkbooks
literally I have literally remember I'll
come to spandana which is one of our
almost went bankrupt we did do some work
with them and you could see that you
know when we would go out of the office
somebody else would walk in and that
person looked like a venture capitalist
so there was literally these people were
standing outside the door with
checkbooks and that and so they created
very large incentives for expansion
because the way you make money in any
bank is by expanding your capital base
so that created in central expansion of
talk about what that that that did to
the in industry and but in particular
they had a very strong incentive to keep
that story going this is no Tom this is
not just a business it's a business that
saved the world that created all the
social venture funds were checkbooks
immediately jumped out of people's
pockets so that was the second piece of
it a third of bigger is that this was
all happening outside the political
system that were in some ways was its
attraction to many people but there was
also one of its weaknesses that the
political system of the politicians
in the state of Andhra Pradesh were
particularly sensitive to the idea that
you know alone is a very good way to pay
people off just before an election and
if these loans are coming from the
private sector then we're not going
getting credit it's a very alone is a
special loan that you can write off just
before the election is a wonderful way
to have political leverage so they were
very keen to be in on that game and the
government interestingly in
collaboration with the World Bank was
pushing its own microcredit program
called Villa GU which they was pushing
very hard and the World Bank was you
know I mean I got a very irate phone
call from the World Bank representative
after for that program saying you guys
you should be evaluating our program
showing how how good it is why are you
working with the private sector so the
World Bank for some interesting
political reason while actually acting
against the private sector they're with
the government so that that was a
another interesting and sort of random
element in that story so there were
these the politicians had their own plan
for this whole thing so no and then what
happened was a you know relatively me
actually stop and say so what happened
was that the politicians basically we're
looking for a leverage point this is
there were certain set of suicides that
happened I'm sure a few of those
suicides had something to with
microcredit I mean or at least people
who committed suicide had borrowed I
surely and therefore there was a
leverage point and then
that story the press took up that story
which is a you know press a good story
you know some poor people borrowed money
and then they couldn't repay they could
they have to commit suicide that that
story I think in some instances I'm sure
it wasn't even true and then that then
created a very nice opportunity for the
political system to step in so I let me
I'm going to spend least time on the
corruption part of the story I think the
corruption part of the story is sort of
predictable the political system wanted
to be in on it they couldn't get it they
were looking for an opportunity to get
it that seems you know kind of not that
interesting
what is interesting I would say is more
howdy how this sort of the
superstructure for that intervention was
created so how why is it that suddenly
at that point they felt empowered to
step in because you know if this was a
successful intervention politicians also
know which way the winds are blowing it
was when the when the opinion maker
started speaking out against this this
particular intervention that they then
felt that look you know now it's time
for us to step in so the sequence was
not that the politicians stepped in
first it was a politician stepped in
after the opinion started moving against
it and that that ID so the interesting
question to me is more why did the
opinions go against microcredit how did
how did come from being this miracle to
this sort of this awful thing so this
was a very interesting Courtley this is
the former governor of the indian like
the like when the india's ben bernanke
so he's not somebody who was supposed to
be you know he doesn't shoot his mouth
usually he's a he's a central banker so
he came out with this statement which
you can you can read this was basically
you know he he he argued that this was
you know the
the equivalent of the subprime crisis
that these were loans that were pushed
onto people which they could not finance
and therefore the whole thing had was
right for collapse so you know and the
world see journal not usually some big
supporter of government programs agreed
so it also stood the view that somehow
this was a symptomatic of some you know
failure in finance no as a point of fact
this was false this was not what at all
what was wrong with the progress with
much the fact that there's lots of
things I'll say in a minute that we're
not right with my credit where nothing
to do with the subprime crisis the
quarters of the subprime crisis was the
in the fact that there was a lot of
people who could not repay who had who
had borrowed the repayment rates in the
Mike just before the micro clearance
crisis the repayment rates where ninety
nine percent or ninety eight percent
depending on how who you believe
microcredit organizations sometimes
massage their repayment rates but some
extremely high number there was no so
the reason so the crisis happened not
because they were unsecured loans that
were being offered to people which were
then could not be collected but because
the government actually stepped in to
make those loans unsecured so the
government basically said don't repay
then then of course you got it so there
was nothing in the crisis that looked
like the subprime crisis there was no no
the lending was I think in a sense argue
in a big to say almost certainly not the
case that these loans were being given
to people who didn't repay these people
were repaying quite predictably in a
sense the interesting question was so
the the key element the subprime crisis
was people giving loans based on the
idea that you know once I've given the
lawn and will sell the loan to someone
else it's gonna be somebody else's
problem this was not at all
these loans were kept on their books
almost none of
loans were sold the small proportion of
them that were sold under a specific
program that had already been shut down
about two years before so there were no
loan all the lungs were kept on their
books so they had every incentive to
collect on this loan so these were not
loans that were given with the view that
you know I'm going to just sell them off
on the as securitized loans to someone
else so these were loans that were on
their books and their prices had nothing
to do with the subprime crisis I think
that's what what what I think it did
have to do with the subprime crisis was
at the level of the rhetoric and and the
level of the rhetoric the subprime
crisis was in a sense symptomatic of
something that held want to happen in
microcredit which is this massive buy
into the idea that finance will save the
world and in in in the in in the
developing world was the idea the
microcredit will eliminate or eradicate
poverty in the in the West it was the
idea that finance has eliminated risk as
we know it so somehow the fact that this
market is the fact that people were you
know pricing these securitized loans at
absurd prices was not was seen as being
the miracle of modern private financed
rather than bad judgment and so in that
sense people were buying into an idea
without actually examining it that that
I think it's at that level these are
very similar problems people were buying
I want to take you through what was I
think both evident from for a long time
but none of us were facing up to in a
sense in in how much local area so we
were buying into ideas that which were
sort of this narrative of microfinance
which we bought into had these four
elements and I want to look at look at
each of them in a minute so the poor
have a strong desire to be entrepreneurs
that's number one number two is
entrepreneurship way out of poverty
number three is
these people because they are naturally
entrepreneurial or because their women
are the different versions of the story
repay loans for reasons which we won't
explain so I'll come back to that
question why do they repay these loans
that was taken as given and then as a
result of all these things microfinance
is commercially viable
so those what was the premise of the
story that you know basically you have
this this whole population of people
hungry to be entrepreneurs just feed
them the capital they pull themselves
with we're up with their you know good
strings out of poverty while at the same
time retaining all the loans because
they are somehow different that that
sort of the narrative that microfinance
is created and we'll what I want you to
do is sort of come for a sort of a ride
through what we know on these subjects
is it for example is it the case that
the poor want to be entrepreneurs I
think all the evidence is so here's the
two facts that seem contradictory but
are not one the poor are overwhelmingly
sort of in entrepreneurial occupations
so you count farming as an
entrepreneurial occupation which is I
think reasonable in many countries for
example India or Bangladesh a huge
fracture of the poor are entrepreneurs
in the sense that they take they bear
the risk of their businesses they they
they the borrow money they they invest
they get the return so they're
entrepreneurs in a classic sense of the
word whoa and that's a huge majority of
the poorer entrepreneurs in that sense
now what is what is interesting is that
we see very little evidence of they are
trying to make you know making make
those businesses that invest in so try
to grow them so every so for example the
median firm is tiny that of course could
could could be a could be because they
don't have any
money but even if you take people who
are much richer so people who take
people who live under a dollar a day
their forms have no employees and no
machines if you take the people who live
between two and four dollars a day or
much richer like two or three times
richer you see exactly the same sizes so
it's not the fact that these people much
richer people are not growing the funds
suggest that they're these firms are not
meant to be grown rather than they can't
afford it because and you if you look at
a lot of these firms we calculated how
much is a capital stock work and you
look at that number that number looks
like 5% of the family expenditures so
you put easily by cutting back for
example the money of this family spend
more on tea than they spend on their
capital stock so there's a sense in
which these firms are the reason why
they're small is not because these
people couldn't grow these forms but
because they choose not to that that's a
so that's pay maybe speculation but we
could look at this quite quite carefully
when you look at when you look at the in
we did an impact evaluation of access to
credit so what what what we do in
poverty action lab is we do these
large-scale randomized experiments where
some neighborhoods microcredit was
offered other neighborhoods about a
fifty two neighborhoods microcredit was
offered another fifty two it was not we
surveyed say about 7,000 families and so
to look at you know what did this access
to microcredit do well and so the way
this so these were my these this was
working with one of the largest
microcredit organizations in India at
that time since then almost bankrupt so
first fact is exactly what I said
most people have businesses okay so 31%
of these people have have businesses
second you know some of them have more
than one business on the other hand
these businesses are tiny only 10% have
any employees 20% have any have no
assets whatsoever and most of them are
in these very very generic industries
like being being happy selling fruits or
general stores or being a tailor etc
businesses that you know make this this
number is how much profits they make on
average these businesses are not very
profitable this is less than minimum
wages basically so then but maybe that's
that's all they can do but here's some
interesting fact that so what's the
effect of getting these loans
well first fact is that when you get
these loans so these are people who get
the loans loser don't you see an
increase in the number of new businesses
but that increase is just 1.7 percent so
you know it's not that when you offer
people these loans everybody runs out
and takes off long and such businesses
in fact only twenty twelve eighteen
percent take the loans offered so not
everybody takes the loans and those who
take the loans they spend it mostly not
on their businesses so here's a here's a
nice fact this is how much they spend on
beauty business durables so when you
don't get along you spend 5.3 rupees
which is ten cents per per head per
month that's that still you know maybe a
family of five so fifty cents four
months that's six dollars a year isn't
that what do they do but it's not that
they don't spend the durables they are
buying durables all the time the average
per-capita expansion durables is hundred
and sixteen rupees that's sort of you
know just a multiple of that so that's
more than twenty times that number so in
other words they're buying televisions
these what are they buying buying
television they're buying refrigerators
they're buying pots pans gold jewelry
all kinds of stuff they're not buying
business durable these numbers just a
scale of this numbers so indeed when you
get a loan you you add seven more rupees
per month you know 30 cents more per
month on your durable but you're not
you're adding that 30 cents not three
hundred dollars and whereas you do add
22 rupees more to the to the
refrigerators and televisions that DVD
players you buy so these people when
they get so if you think that the reason
why the businesses are small is because
they don't have any money it's clear
that even when you give them the money
they don't grow their business if they
do other things
now I there's a reason why they do that
and then it's not surprising this has
essentially no effect on total
consumption you know people don't it
doesn't affect how much how much how
much they buy and finally there's all
kinds of other implied promises for
example there was I think in the early
days on cGAP which is the World Bank's
whole banks so winged for dealing with
things like microcredit on the website
they would have description of all the
things that microcredits going to do
that included a reducing HIV prevalence
for example so we didn't measure HIV
prevalent it's too expensive to measure
but we did measure for example our
children going more likely to go to
school due to microcredit these are
exactly the same height are they more
sick due to microcredit no are they
spending more on health no so you know
all the things that serve all the other
social impacts you don't see them it's
not very surprising basically you look
at what the money is doing it's going
most in into buying televisions and
that's that's roughly what is going on
and I know I want to take the view that
this is not there's nothing surprising
about this we just we
you are prepared to buy into the story
that the poor are biting at the you know
they're just desperate to become
entrepreneurs and therefore we sort of
expected something different but there's
nothing surprising about this we did a
survey where we asked people what would
just you want your son to become when he
grows up or your grandson suppose you
have a 15 year old and then we rephrase
the question different way for example
we ask them imagine you want a lottery
so you have some money to help your son
do something with you with his life what
would you want him to do so 80% say we
would want him to be get a government
job another 20% say we want to get him a
private sector job 0% mentioned starting
a business so you know this is starting
a business is what poor people do
because they have no alternatives it's
not because they were what they want to
do and then when they start a business
they also do it lackadaisically it's not
that they are desperately trying to grow
as fast as possible they're trying to
somehow this is just another bit of
income that they're trying to find from
somewhere and that all the evidence fits
that story that this is like you know
the last bit - then they can think they
can do to add a little bit more to the
family income rubberband
this is some you know major driver
towards you know liberation from poverty
so now I'm gonna come back this is not
necessarily I don't at all want to say
I'll come back to this one it's very
important to what I want to say this is
you should not see this as criticism of
microcredit I have seen a little bit
what the good things that it does but
III think it's very important to
understand that the narrative was of
entrepreneurship why was it important to
have a narrative of entrepreneurship
because the presumption was that the
question that people worried about is if
these poor people are taking these loans
how will they repay them so then the
entrepreneurship was a natural answer to
that question if it closed that circle
right here you now you know
they used the story was that
entrepreneurship is going to close that
circle and entrepreneurship is not I
mean all I want to point out right now
that entrepreneurship is not what's
going to close that circle something
else you'll see what what does in a
little bit I'll come back to that so the
second point was that as I said first
point was that you know entrepreneurship
is it's going to be through
entrepreneurship second thing was that
repayment rate very high now some of
that was creative accounting but mostly
after you look past all being creative
accounting I think repayment rates were
remarkably high they were certainly over
95% and if you look at small businesses
in the US for example small business
loans in the u.s. have 10% or default
rates so these were very very high
repayment rates so this the next
question was if it is not
entrepreneurship why won't we why
weren't we worried about the fact these
loans were being repaid why is that why
do we take here is given that these
loans can be repaid if it is we once
once the Entrepreneurship hoop goes away
it lets less seems less clear why how is
it that these poor people can repay all
these loans if they're not investing it
in productive businesses so the first
answer to that was that somehow these
guys so one one answer which for example
I wrote a paper or this many years 20
years ago saying that this is because of
group liability so one one three element
of microcredit used to be that basically
these are group loans so when when I
default I I have a group of people who
borrow with me and they're liable for
the loan so they they will then have to
repay it back so basically there
so the claim one one claim was as well
reason why people don't default is
because they'll offend their friends so
somehow
all kind of know there's empirical
evidence on this question Dean Karlan
who you must know in the economics
department here looks at this the heat
they do an experiment where they
basically compare groups which were
formed under joint liability with groups
which were formed on the individual
liability and find no no difference in
the payment rates so there's not much
evidence that the repayment rates are
very different because of group
liability so again evidence suggests
that that was not the answer what
another theory was that well these guys
repay because they want to get another
loan problem with that stories they'd
never hung together well you know if if
you are going to you know the basically
the growth rate of these loans is pretty
small okay you know at most if you get
you repay a loan loan of 10,000 rupees
you'll get 12 thousand rupees but
remember you you you pay 24 percent on
this run of ten thousand rupees so you
want to end up repaying much more than
you would get in a new loan and what you
go to get as a result is not a gift
no they're a loan which you have to
repay why would you be pay because
you're gonna get one just the numbers
just don't add up with if they were
going to get a million dollar loan for
repaying maybe they would take it take
it but a loan that's a few thousand
rupees more why would you repay a loan
to get another loan if you just kept
your 10,000 rupees ten thousand rupees
plus interest so that's more than twelve
thousand rupees you'd be better off so
that can't be the answer either
so in some sense again I'm pointing to a
certain intellectual failure that you
know we we didn't ask ourselves the
question why were these people repent we
sort of told offs of the stories
entrepreneurship these people somehow
maybe maybe these group liability things
are working so I give me
let me give kind of partial answer to
the question of pipe well why were
people actually repair it's worth
understanding because that tells us also
where the weakness of the system work so
part of the answer is I think the more
is sort of mundane but but interesting
the microcredit design is quite clever
so you don't never repay a whole loan at
one time you repay your loan of 10,000
rupees you repaint 50 installments so
basically what that does is it allows
you to every repayment is a small amount
of money so when you when you're taking
the decision shall I make this payment
or not it's always sort of enough money
that you could just pay it back you have
the money at hand so it's never puts a
huge pressure on people that's part of I
think part of the design where when you
when you actually allow people to repay
every month rather than every week the
repayment obviously goes up by a factor
of four and you start to see much much
more default because then it's not a
trivial amount of money anymore when it
comes to repayment day it's actually a
significant amount of money and people
start to start defaulting so that sort
of fits the second piece of that is that
there is a clear social norm there that
basically basically basically when
people repair when others do how did we
see that there's a very nice paper by
somebody was on the we just finished her
PhD from MIT she looks at this pattern I
would explain this pattern in a man it's
so what what she looks at is a crisis
that happened in microcredit in 2006 in
2006 one district in the same state of
under Pradesh the
the head of the district basically the
governor of the district had declared
exactly what was done then for the whole
state before he said don't repeat so
whole bunch of people defaulted
obviously when after the default there
was some negotiation microcredit was
again reopened and he was shunted out so
it was restored but now take those
people who had already defaulted the
microcredit organization went back to
them and said okay if you repay your
loan will allow you to repay it over
however long you want and once you repay
it will give you a new loan so they were
trying to bring them back in today now
questions who who participated in that
offer and who didn't and it turns out
that basically the best predictor of who
participated in that was whether or not
in your group other people will also
participate in particular they were a
nice way to look at that is to look at
what this picture says microcredit loans
happen to be on a 50 week cycle so the
fractional so if you are young in week
49 then you have to just pay one more
installment back and then you would get
a new loan so think of people who had
defaulted because they were told to
default some of them were one week away
from getting a new loan others were 50
weeks away from getting a new loan take
the people who one week away they were
very strong and sent to repay now
suppose everybody else in my group is
one week away but I'm 50 weeks away well
I don't have much more in central
default repay but all my friends are
repaid so what Emily looks at in this
picture what it shows is that your
repayment isn't is a very nicely
predicted actually I'll show you this
this pictures
so basically if if if other people if
you have close you know close to fifty
weeks you are much more likely to depend
so what she looks at is what happens if
you are 50 you are at week zero let's
say so you you are or week one so very
far away from getting a new lawn but all
your friends are in week 50 over a week
49 and what she shows is that people who
are whose friends are in week 49 but
they themselves are week one are much
more likely to repay then people who are
in week who are in week 25 but their
friends are in week one so basically
what happens is that if other people
around you are repaying you repay so why
is that important that says that somehow
it was a social norm to repay you care
about whether other people are repaying
or not
why is that important because it says
that you are the microfinance
organization had a huge stake in
convincing everyone that repaying was a
good thing to do because if everyone
else you paid I will repay so basically
people repay because other people are
repay the microcredit the organization
therefore has a lot of stake in making
people feel good about repayment so what
part microcredit organizations I think
the big big piece of why people repaid
was it they was they saw this
organization as some friendly
organization that the norm was that you
should behave well towards them I think
that was a very big piece of why people
repay therefore when when this norm was
undone so so it was it was very
important for the so when you look at
when the microcredit organization were
were was able to collect it was able to
collect when when but or how he was able
to collect was able to collect on the
loans mostly by putting social pressure
on people by saying that this is bad
behavior
and so there was very little evidence
that her actually putting a threatening
people so they were really what happened
the typical story was I hate this
microcredit guy when I don't repay he
comes and stands outside my house
it was Shamy that was because and why
the shaming work but shaming works when
the norm is to behave in a particular
way when it is when people accept that
repaying the loan is the right thing to
do when when people think it's a prompt
thing to do then the fact that is
waiting outside my door doesn't matter
he's an idiot he's waiting there so what
so you it was come he was a system that
worked very much through this kind of
social social norm what what why is that
important what that meant that in
particular it was the idea that these
organizations were morally right was
extremely important for the organization
a very nice instance of that was even
before this did earlier default there
was a very nice little incident that
happened this is in 2006 I think
suddenly a set of pliers
appeared from nowhere claiming that the
woman who who ran Spandana which is the
organization we worked with had murdered
her husband these were fake newspaper
stories in Telugu which is a local
language which was circulating
everywhere so she showed us one well it
was a picture of her saying that she's
she's police are looking for her she's
absconding she's murdering her husband
why because if they wanted to undermine
the put her moral standing so the idea
that you repaid this organization
organization because it's a good
organization is how do you undermine
that by showing that it's no
she murders her husband she's a bad
woman so it was so this hold so the
whole political game was played on this
nexus of the moral claim that these guys
were doing good rather than doing doing
sort of hurting people and that's why I
think here it that's all goes back to
why I think it's very important to
understand the rhetorical case for this
the for microcredit because it's
precisely microcredit success relied on
everybody buying into the idea that
microcredit is a morally a good thing
now that of course is what makes it very
made it very difficult for them what
else could they do I mean this this this
this i i'm not criticizing them for
making this claim because they had they
had no collateral it didn't they had no
they were basically they didn't
repossess you know most money lenders
will repossess your land or take away
your jewelry they were not basically
doing any of that how could how could
they how could they get the loan well
they get it by shaming people so and
sometimes people get shamed and they
commit suicide
so everything that happened we could
have anticipated would have happened had
to happen within the system once we
understood once you asked ourselves a
question why how can these people
collect on these loans because after all
you know these long bones are real money
why would people pay them back so the
end the whole system was turned on these
two axes one was we are a morally good
organization and the second was that
second was that you know there was we
are going to oh we are going to come and
shame you if you because we're a morally
good organization we're gonna shame you
if you don't pay your loan so that was
the core business model so once you
recognize that you can see why a that
really fragile because you know
it will be a lot of contested moral
claims and second you will see you can
see that this will occasionally lead to
people you know committing suicide
because they're going to feel that you
know I am failing my family I am
somebody was bringing shame on my family
a lot of these people who committed
suicide she said exactly those who used
exactly those what so that all of that
that kind of my point is mostly that
this was predictable that this was what
had to have been going on and we didn't
actually read read what was going on
carefully enough or we would have known
what's going on so what happened in the
crisis was that you know known officers
were you know they had they had strong
incentives to collect they were the
Egypt you know we clearly want your loan
officers to have strong incentives and
microcredit organs were very explicit
about it they took their you know people
who if you can't collect your lawn your
bonus is gone so that was very clear so
there's a lot of competition microcredit
organizations where you know people were
chasing these organizations with pots of
money so they had lots of money to give
out so they went to like many people had
six seven different loans why because
you know every organization in the area
could get money from somebody to lend to
them so they were lending so a lot of
people had a lot of difficulty paying
back some people were - this was growing
over time as the venture capital money
flowed in there were more and more loans
people were more and more you know under
the water the pressure was on then I
mean I think he is that and from one of
the organization's the only one that's
really survived out of this crisis was
August called SKS the head of SKS you'll
see in a boy I will charge you an
interview with it but SKS was an
organization which
sort of in 2008 early 2009 had an IPO
that I feel raised I think 200 million
dollars so why was that important it
suddenly exposed the fact that these
guys were making money now if you
thought about it why were they doing
this they were claiming all kinds of
things but you know they were businesses
they were venture capitalists were
willing to lend to them so we could have
seen that they were making money and it
was clear that they were making money
they weren't actually if you look at the
margins the margins are cheap pretty
small it's not that I'm making money
they were making money on volume huge
body relatively small margin but they
were market making money but once that
came became front and center because of
his IPO everybody suddenly struck
everybody these guys are making money
the moral flame immediately was weakened
very substantially and the moral claim
is central to to all of this by how
microcredit operates so in some sense
once this moral claim is undermined you
know it's its ability to enforce loans
is much weaker the moral claim is that
for all so I was arguing that it's very
important to understand that they were
based on the idea that we are a good
organization we're doing good everybody
bought into it once that's not getting
questioned everything started unraveling
and as a result you know the rest of the
story is kind of obvious the ones that
started unraveling more people were
reluctant to repay politicians were more
happy to go and tell them don't repay
everything kind of started unraveling so
it's some some sense this combination of
being built on a moral claim and and
having no other form of enforcement made
them very very fragile so there was
nothing else
once it once your moral claim is
contested then at that point what else
do you have that keeps you going so
that's sort of I think fundamentally
what happened
so this is a bit maybe in their specific
so let me skip this I want to actually
come come back to so what what would you
do how would you get out of this well I
think I think what what my career has
never did and this is interesting that
the rhetoric went in the direction it
did was that they didn't emphasize that
they were extremely effective lenders so
if you look at the interest rates the
same people pay on loans to money
lenders they're paying something like
four percent per month but like 80
percent 60 percent a year four percent
of one compounded is sixty something
percent a year so what these guys were
charging something like two percent a
month or less how did they manage to
lower the interest rate especially since
they were not taking collateral the two
things one is this what I emphasize
people were willing to repay but this is
also a very clever technological
innovation the very clever technology
innovation was so simple that nobody
actually pushed it but I think it's
probably the most important thing they
did think of how a loan repayment
happens with for the moneylender he sits
in his shop people come by and they pay
some money for that to be effective or
to because you're you he has to be there
all the time because otherwise people
will say I came to repair but you went
there so that requires somebody sitting
in one place for a very long time sort
of always waiting for the money to come
in
what microcredit did was two related
innovations one is if everyone was
formed into a group so group of between
five and twenty five people who are all
supposed to repay in this
same time and that time is designated
extremely sharply so 10 past 7:00 every
Wednesday why is that important that
means that when I show up everybody is
obliged to pay then I'm not waiting for
those people input and in particular if
somebody can't come the reason why
people were put into groups is if
somebody can't come I know somebody else
in my neighborhood is it that same group
I can go give her the money and she can
take it in and repay for me so basically
that combination meant that in a given
day a Michael a loan officer could
collect hundreds of loans on a given day
that's what made microcredit very cheap
because basically the covering the cost
of someone who's there to collect is
very expensive when the loans are of
this tiny these tiny loans when you are
ten thousand rupees two hundred dollar
loans you know covering the cost of
somebody who's collecting is extremely
expensive because that person's time is
valuable so by using these loan officers
very very effectively they manage to get
the cost down this is something that
they never emphasized but I think this
is key to understanding their technology
and why they have these groups and why
why they have you know why have they
have these they try to have identical
known sizes for everybody why because if
I have identical loan size for everybody
then everybody repays the same amount
then I just sort of count I don't even
have to total the amount I can just
count you know 25 people all paid I know
what they have to pay I'm done I can
save another two minutes so this process
innovation was completely central to I
think how they managed to make money and
very relatively low interest rates so
that's first
I think they should they they are
actually very innovative organizations
the second thing that they didn't do is
they didn't
because they emphasized the fact that
you know this is all automatic these
people can repay because they're citing
businesses they missed a trick which is
that the poor actually need money they
were a lot of poor people want to buy
televisions but they can never buy it
because saving money at home is too
difficult if you imagine you have to
save $300 at home fifty you know fifty
cents at a time it's just never going to
happen what's the evidence for that
so people so first I think people manage
to realize you know it so one of the
things we looked at is what happens I'll
just emphasize there's a lot of
definitions here ignore them but I'll
say one thing so we before we did this
project to microcredit we asked the
people in the micro Vario who the women
who were going to be the subjects of
microcredit what are things you want to
spend less on other things you want to
give up and they listed a set of things
these were things like Tee tee was since
I drink a lot of tea I always I'm struck
by the fact tea fried things snacks
potato chips these kinds of things where
you know cigarettes there's a whole
bunch of things they're listed these are
mostly pretty mundane things but they
when you look at the amount they spend
on that they spend about seven percent
of their total monthly spending is spent
on things like tea snacks chips
cigarettes etc so they now what we did
was we this is the comparison we same
colors that you saw before this is
people who get the loans these people
who don't you get the loan you spend
less on those those things on the chips
and things like that why are they
spending less on the chips that's how
they've repaying the loan how is the
long getting repaid primarily it's
getting repaid by a substantial piece of
it is just cutting back on things other
things so what they're doing is what I
would call consumption transformation
they're turning things that
so be you really want to get to that TV
you want that TV but you can never get
there seen in instead you can satisfy by
buying little snacks here and there once
you have access to the TV
you actually can restrain yourself and
not buy by them and that so you know you
see this is a major fault I mean I just
want to show you this number that number
was down from 69 rupees per head per
month to 29 rupees so less than half of
the spending on so that's sort of that's
a that's a striking decline these are
the people who just want to go back to
that so main point I want to make here
is first I think that it's very it's
very unfair to think of poor people as
people who don't need loans mean they
have aspirations to and loans of a place
to reach our aspirations their ways to
get to if you want to buy a house I
can't afford to go out and buy a house
what I do I do I take a loan why
shouldn't poor people have that same
option they want to buy televisions
think this is a way for them to buy
television so basically the whole
rhetoric of microcredit has been
avoiding this point which is poor people
should have the right to get loans and
they show you the right to buy
televisions that's something we're
always been abiding we've always been
avoiding talking about that and the fact
that you know they're willing to make
sacrifices for that all of that was
never in the conversation we're talking
about you know they're starting
businesses how they're all entrepreneur
they're going to pull out and pull
themselves out of poverty we don't see
much evidence on any of that there were
a bunch of now a bunch of studies from
different countries which all do the
same thing are cities on microcredit
none of them find evidence of people
pulling on themselves out of poverty
all of them find some evidence of this
kind which is that they change the
consumption patterns so very very
interesting
so services there's also some
potentially no this is not just
a static epic it's not just that they
achieve the tea television it's also
that once I think that I have control
over my life I can achieve certain goals
I might be willing to work hard for
those I might be if I if I can't ever
get to the television that I want I
might not have any any you know any sort
of maybe I'm just gonna go try very hard
but if I if I actually think that I can
achieve certain goals in my wife then
and loans are going to if I if I repay
this loan this loan I buy a television
and they pay that next time I buy a DVD
player I might be willing to work hard
for that so there may very well be
dynamic effects of that there's a little
bit of evidence of that which is you
look at these people who are borrowing
but I show no evidence of starting a new
business they don't seem to be falling
into into a death trap there's no
evidence that the people who don't start
a business at all but they keep taking
loans are falling into a debt trap that
suggests that what they're doing is
they're the labor earnings are going up
there working hard outside and
increasing their hunting so there's some
evidence that this might actually
provide exactly the right kind of
incentives but that's all speculation
main point is that there is because the
whole rhetoric is crafted around this
idea of you know automatic repayment
because these are entrepreneurial people
we kind of never ask the right questions
if we ask the right questions and we
thought about what was going on we would
have seen that the story we were telling
didn't fit any of the other facts we
knew if you look at the what fits the
facts it's a story of more of this kind
which is that this is an organization
these guys are actually offering loans
to people who want loans at the rates at
which they would not get elsewhere and
that's good that's a good thing and that
might indeed be even better thing
because this might actually encourage
them to cut back on things that they
don't really want to do like spend money
on tea and get to achieve goals that
they're actually achieving so all of
that makes me think that you know the
microcredit needs to be so repackage
itself reinvent the rhetoric and it's
because in a sense we allowed them to
build a rhetoric that was kind of
implausible and fragile that we ended up
with the crisis so so the sort of mind
so in the end what I want to do is I
want you know I'll show you a video and
end so I think once you are I won't skip
most of the the policy stuff I just want
to show you the video but I want to say
one thing which is that once you agree
that this is not about some kind of
miracle as a solution to the problem of
entrepreneurship and this is just about
giving people loans then you have to be
upfront of the fact Alone's need to be
collected and therefore you need to have
an infrastructure for collecting longze
people need to be if the people need to
pay repay loans and unpleasant as that
might sound once you're up front about
it that could be regulated better but so
I want to end by showing your video
where Vikram Akula who was who started
at SKS which is the IP which had the IPO
that creates started the crisis in a
sense was interviewed on BBC and he was
also in a sense trying to backtrack from
the claims about backtrack from making
too many claims but he has a different
way of doing
no that didn't do it let me see if I can
get to D he was playing just fine when
Steve and I were trying it
sorry really bad
one last try
it's not opening I don't know what it's
it's a pity but it is really amusing
it was a plate
play-doh little needs to be yeah okay
click on this so we
if you look at here's here's one of the
I think the most standard way to
standard way to look at it this one but
this is let me just qualify so this is
this is just for capita expenditure
these numbers are statistically
indistinguishable then certainly not 30
percent therefore for 4838 rupees on
1400 rupees so you know it's certainly
not 30 percent 3 percent so right but
these are tiny numbers the main point I
was making but no it's not cut across
this much more than 30 percent you I
think it's hundred and 20 percent but
it's a hundred twenty percent on zero
it's a I would say I think the relevant
number is is this which is that it
doesn't change your standard of living I
think that's a key fact is that you know
your standard living doesn't change the
number of let me skip this number of you
know kids in school doesn't change
child's illness doesn't change health
expenses and saying this is something
else women are supposed to have more
control as a result of that that doesn't
change nothing observable changes in the
standard of living that's that they seem
to be buying more TVs and eating less
drinking less tea I think that's the the
striking fact seems to be that one which
I I'm happy with I would say I'm all in
favor of people owning what they want to
on if that's television dress television
so so I'm in favor
that I think the rhetoric of increasing
per capita expenditure which is sort of
a standard measure of poverty is it's
just there's no evidence for it so these
are for 18 months we have results up to
36 months in the impact it's at after
that is it one this difference is
slightly negative it's still zero it's
statistically exactly zero but it's
after 36 months is exactly same place
slightly negative now sometimes it's
like this is misused interest with
parties to suggest that we should be
looking into increasing assistance
or even continuing the current level of
assistance to development countries well
you know I mean at some level let here's
not I mean
this is not showing everything's can't
be the answer to that problem so it has
to be that somehow we have to help
people interpret evidence and we have to
fight the battle with their evidence not
by suppressing it I I don't think we can
win the win the battle by hiding hiding
the facts so you know what you're right
sometimes it will happen I mean I
certainly think that it's better to I
think what's happened here is the worst
of all world which is you start with a
fake story then the fake story fails and
the whole thing is then rejected because
of that I would say better to have the
real story which is that this is a great
wait for people to buy televisions and
you know and then say that you know
buying televisions if people want to buy
televisions they should have the right
to do so that would be a better way to
fight the fight this seems to be so
going through this you know creating a
kind of false narrative which then
collapses on its own weight is the worst
of all possible
it would soon be that you know when you
have a shop you you can spend more that
doesn't mean on average we instructor
rare so it's not you would still see the
same numbers I mean especially if you if
you if you might think that small shops
and big shops are negatively correlated
so if you actually have you know if you
see this you see the doctor when you
need to because you're some money in
hand and maybe you will you will may not
have a bigger problem so it's not clear
to me what what you'd expect prime
aphasia on the average spending you know
you don't think that basically you
wouldn't expect I mean that the whole
whole maybe premise of the current
health care reform debate in the u.s. is
that this will reduce costs because
people will use health care better I
mean you know the right will get the
right so it's not the answer is I don't
know no what I would expect
well at least there I think the
narrative is much more straightforward
they are claiming that this is insurance
so at least there's no we didn't we've
done won the preliminary results on a
micro health insurance suggests no
effects but we'll see III think mostly
problem with my micro insurance and
nobody wants it that's the battle that
most people are fighting right now is
that you know you offer it to people
they just don't want it and in the case
of our program that was so desperate
that the organization eventually
abandoned the program because nobody
wanted it they were forcing people to
take it and people were just getting
really upset as a result of that they
were so there was a so maybe one day
people will start wanting it and then
it'll be easier to understand what it
does yeah
it just kind of sounds older like that
so I'm just curious why some of these
people were clearly over-leveraged also
I'm sure they were working very hard to
repay these loans I have no doubt that
this is this is so I mean if you think
of the regulatory point of view I'm sure
that what you really you really don't
want people to have seven loans I think
that's that's completely true I I don't
I don't see any argument for people you
know that there's no I was not making
the case that you shouldn't shouldn't
put any limits on how much lending makes
sense I I certainly think that it's
quite possible to get people to take
loans that they they don't need or are
bad for them I was just making the point
that one shouldn't assume by the fact
that they're not spending it on machines
that this is bad for them which is a
much weaker point in terms of something
else is very different from the subprime
I mean these guys kept all the loans on
their books that's very important
there was no you couldn't sell these
loans so you know if you so you if
you're giving a loan that somebody can't
repay substantially that's your risk now
there's some problem because the sum is
not clear that you know what it's not
clear that the seniority of the loans is
well-defined so imagine I'll learn
to someone and mushrik length to someone
who's loan will get prepaid first is an
issue so maybe I'm going to say you know
even if most food has already lent to
her I'm going to go online to her say
and encourage it to default or mushrik
instead so you know there is some
potentially negative competition which
was going on so I I think there are real
issues in what you are saying I I'm
certainly in favor of a fair amount of
regulation I just think that one
shouldn't misinterpret what the point of
this whole thing
I'm not sure there is one
I think they they're pretty pretty a
pretty I haven't seen real evidence
I mean you could make the argument I
think the reason are going to be made
which is that you know imagine I want to
give money to a poor person what's the
least poorest way to do it and think of
a just a purely distributive cause there
may well be that this is a very
efficient way to do it at least these
organizations tend to be relatively
relatively easy to regulate they tend to
be relatively transparent so maybe they
are passing on the money and if you give
it try to give them the money through
other mechanisms they just won't arrive
so I think it has to be an argument
based on this is the most effective way
to redistribute rather than televisions
are good for people I mean they may well
be but I wasn't going to make that case
some kind of dilemma between the
conviction and being worried you know
they're saying that be morally good at
the institution but the same time if you
look back on equation
[ __ ] the moral part of it even I mean
your question is stands even without
that it's just you know how much how
should we regulate an industry which has
in principle we don't know necessarily
want to make too much competition in it
but what's too was too much and how do
we know it's not too little competition
hard question I I mean I think the way
people have suggested dealing with it is
to have basically a minimum and maximum
number of lenders per area and regulate
basically market entry but I don't think
there's any good good science on on that
I don't know that you know the right
numbers 3 or 5 or to anybody's thought
about it's but it's a good question I
don't know the answer to it but it's
it's sort of out there
yeah so well I mean it's based on I
don't know whether you'd call it
paternalism argument but yes our women
about households not being able to
implement long-term consumption plans I
think there's plenty of evidence that
they can't so I I don't know whether
that's paternalism it's certainly
argument about people not being able to
you know I mean if the premise is that
people can't save up to get a TV at home
favorite home to get a TV that's the
premise so there clearly there is
somewhere there is an implementation
constraint whether that's because you
know your husband steals the money or
you steal your own money that's I can
tell ya but some something like that
must be in there otherwise the story
doesn't hang together
so actually you know it's interesting is
that I don't think I mean I think
commitments enemies products of course
one side are very very attractive on the
other side people often don't go the
take-up of those tend to be very limited
because people think that you know what
I have if I need to even save the
counties for the poor I think there is
there's a there's a significant case to
be made to have just savings accounts
for the poor without any explicit
commitment I think the evidence is very
positive on on the savings I don't know
I'm arguing that one should not have a
moral moral rhetoric that's fake you
know I have nothing against a moral
movement if somebody is willing to give
our loans under market price that's fine
with me
I have nothing against people trying to
do things for non non economic reasons
if they want to do it that's more power
to them so I don't want to argue that it
needs to be an industry all I do want to
say that it it can't possibly claim X
and do y
I mean if you see in Bangladesh there is
a clearly simmering crisis there I think
that I think the main point is that any
any organization that is of this kind of
size and has a lot of four very large
footprint among the poor is vulnerable
to political attack because it's it's
it's the government seizes these things
has been very powerful so they're all so
I think it's all the story is I want to
tell this one where the important
question is what did how does the
government justify in attacking them and
then you need to have some some entry
point I think what what all the the way
they had structured the directive had
created a set of entry points and that
then the government used that with the
sort of ones once you think it's claimed
that it's all for you know public good
that you're doing it then at that point
when it shows that you are profitable
that's that's proof that you're not
doing it for the public good so I think
if they had not emphasized their
charitable face as much and had said
we're a business we're just finding the
effective way to deliver loans to the
poor then I think they would not have
attracted as much money from outside and
they might have had had to be more
exclusive or their enforcement
mechanisms but on the other hand they
would have had then you would not be in
fact that you're making money would not
have been news you would have said we
are making money so I think they're just
different they're just different the
government will always look for
I think Grameen Bank age is very
powerful with monetization that's just
how it is
so governments will always find them
attract and then you they'll have to
think of ways to construct their own
rhetoric to not and their different ways
to do it I mean brac certainly does it
in Bangladesh does it by doing a
delivery of home range of other services
so they don't see seen it they're not
primarily seen as as a micro lender even
though they are very large remember
that's a different ways to sort of place
yourself in the political
the moneylenders at least the political
base support for moneylenders is very
limited so a lot of people you need my
letter cause you that bit so big so be
it
I think people care much less about that
and absolutely well I think primarily it
was also that they just had much less
moral claim and therefore you know
moneylender typically in all the
rhetoric is is and all the literature is
the iboga so you know the fact that he's
trying to you know claim that you have
defaulted on him well power to you you
know he's the evil guy well I agree the
fact that Dave Mack got the lending
could be a good thing or a bad thing is
very important what they're being able
to use social social mechanisms
the Prime Minister not to discount
the extent that it should carry because
I'm not sure that it needs you know it
can sustain industry the size it was I'm
not sure the industry beside it was
necessarily especially on the book is a
good thing when there wasn't there was a
huge amount of lending so you know maybe
not okay I I just think that this
particular kind of selling of the whole
thing with me is not going to be
sustainable
I just think whether it should be or
shouldn't be it is even a different
question I'm mostly saying I don't
believe that it will be people buy it I
think people are now very skeptical and
I don't think that I mean just the too
many things have now pointed to the fact
that these guys are and not exactly who
they're claiming to be and I don't think
they can restore that and I think they
had started from the beginning by kind
of putting the cards on the table then
that particular thing would not have
happened maybe they would not have grown
as fast all kinds of other things would
happen but this particular story was
clearly driven by the fact that they
were telling a story that in the end
exploded in their face